[موسيقى]
عده المؤرخون اخر علماء غرناطه الافداد
يحيى بن احمد بن هديل ابو زكريا التجيبي
الغرناطي الارجوني نسبه الى مدينه ارجدون
شاعر وطبيب وفيلسوف واطلع على علوم اخرى
منها الهندسه والحساب والاصول والهدف
ولد في غرناطه ولم يحدد المؤرخون تاريخ
ميلاده على وجه الدقه وان كان ولد بين
القرنين الثاني عشر والثالث عشر للميلاد
عمل مدرسا للفرائض والاصول والطب في مدرسه
غرناطه وطبيبا في البلاط السلطاني
اشتهر بتقاهو ومؤانساته للحضور وقوه الحفظ
وسعه العلم
من مؤلفاته الطبيه تصنيف الاختيار
والاعتبار وكتاب التذكره في الطب وشرح
كراسه الراس في الطب
اضافه الى علومه الطبيه برع بن هديل في
الشعر وكان له ديوان حمل اسم السليمانيات
والعربيات وتنشيط الكسل
عاش اخر ايامه مشلولا وزاد عليه وفاه
زوجته فصاحبه وجد شديد فلما قربت وفاته
استدعت الميده العلامه الشهير لسان الدين
بن الخطيب واملى عليه بعض الابيات اذ كان
لسانه لا يبين القول ولا يفصح عما يريد
توفي على الراجح في العام
1352 للميلاد في مدينه غرناطه بالاندلس
[موسيقى]